[Música]
uma planta gente é tão vamos tentar
fazer qualquer coisa com isto vou perder
o ovo é que vamos ver o que é que o
entendimento é que o novo tamanho ver
não faz idéia do que em 321 ontem outra
coisa que em cada bola a todo o pessoal
aqui quem fala é dar que seja muito bem
vindo a chamar já que os estragos de que
o mistério o mistério da floresta que
por trás da colômbia é flor e eu não sei
se vocês lembram as viram esse vídeo
mexe eu achei o ovos muito estranho
sakineh por esta inclusive os jogos
ainda lá estão mas provavelmente eu acho
que são ovos podem pontos todos podres
então eu vou fazer aqui nesse período só
vou tentar quebrar um mas só vamos
descobrir isso neste vídeo só é portanto
a companhia até o fim vai ser muito
louco eu já tenho aqui deus canta eu vou
montar agora isto tudo e vou passar para
o lado de lá mas para lá pessoal vamos
lá então por lá não antes só vou
precisar muito da vossa ajuda agora o
negócio é que os pilotos de corrida que
eu disse para vocês lutaremos pelos
ganharem a corrida é isso vamos fazer
outra vez porque estão a ganhar tudo
tudo basta clicar em um link em baixo
primeiro da instituição podem entrar à
vontade e isso não é visto não é só tem
de nos podem entrar entrei lá pessoal e
clique em lutar com o facebook você
entrou lá com o facebook tal e vai por
ser uma mistura piloto gigante o que
você escolheu 12 tanques fotos
impressionantes piloto e pôs cá em baixo
vai por ser um botãozinho dizer que o
pulso para chegar lá e pronto feito voto
é só perder 15 do pessoal então ajudar
bastante já agora deixem também muito
aqui neste vídeo para saber se vocês
estão aqui está muito obrigada campo e
já e agora vamos finalmente subir a
nossa floresta assombrada que ele está
assombrado realmente o labor e andré
pimentel pt comida eu tenho um coach u
o liceo
ah ah não tem jeito pra isto é que então
a dar um é ou tem qualquer coisa de
frente que vejam só que aconteceu jogos
o que aconteceu aqui o mundo está
partido ronnie isso eis aqui um sortido
alguém possui até verde com isso é muito
fofo obra é um fator 2 ataque um toque
leitão inteiro o pessoal acha que
apareceu um ovo porque consegui
encontrar um partido um interno e outro
eu não sei onde está e eu já dei uma
volta e não se conectar não tem qualquer
coisa aqui sim alguém pensou prestado
pelo menos eu não sei se foi jardineiro
mas é impossível porque eu acho que
daqui a escada então eu não consegui
sequer ou então foi algum animal que
pegou o vôo pra algum até porque eu
acabei por não fazer nenhum e não
coloquei os jogos de volta na árvore com
qualquer animal que este gene pode ter
cuidado fica falta né
mas vamos continuar aqui procurar pessoa
que alguém não houve este trilha sinto o
meu deus alguém anda na floresta do dark
estava infeliz hóquei vou tentar entrar
aqui numa destas áreas
consegui aqui tem mais caminho sim já
conseguiram uma barreira ao i jovem uma
barreira corro e não se conseguem ver
mas tem uma barreira à frente e pelo
barulho dos carros e disse que só pode
ser a barreira que separa a estrada do
mato te peço à floresta mas vamos
avançar aqui já dá pra andar alguém
andou que sim é impossível não conseguia
andar aqui ô ô ô só tem uma armadilha
lhe uma planta de espinhos vou tentar
pular aqui ó
e isso consegui passar até muito sol
aqui quando a cantora que já sei o que
vou acampar e que nesse debate muito bem
o sol afinal de contas o que nos
interessa agora é encontrar os jogos
então vamos lá em busca do ouro eu
tentava pessoal eu tentar voltar mas
está muito complicado e mexe eu vou
ficar com alguma coisa nas minhas costas
e até mesmo a prisão mesmo jogo foi o
terceiro
o que é que está o ovo desapareceu
eu deixei o suspeito deste caso
aqui tem um ovo aqui tem um novo partido
e isso aqui pode ser outro desportivo
não não acho é que isto tem um monstro
aqui o ou tem outro uso aqui grosso é
este que já precisamos então no deus
alguém andou por aqui sim por aí tá
muito mais abertos treino ele não estava
assim para isso consiga andar aqui muito
bem agora agora tu ficarás estado sim
porque isso não estava assim alguém abre
o caminho ontem outra coisa que em cada
[Música]
rota
esse é um copo original aqui bole só a
série chega muito podre aqui mas não só
a quantidade de moscas é tem muita
música mas bom só vamos avançar
eu não consigo encontrar um outro
ofertados a partida mas pelo menos um eu
tenho então vamos tentar fazer qualquer
coisa com isto vou perder o ovo é que
vamos ver o que é que eu entendo é que o
novo tamanho verde não faz idéia do que
em 321 o everton já vem toda a música
aqui é um animal um animal não me escuso
da província risco o que será isto eu
vou porque um estudo da linha
isso é um galinha não ser muito o poder
só não esqueça que o galinha com 40 ou
qualquer coisa assim acho que foi o
projeto piloto já nem sei mas tem
qualquer coisa amarela que isto lembra
muito uma gema eu mas o povo verde não é
possível não só comentei o que vocês
acham que isto é porque vamos sentar
aqui vou falar um pouquinho com vocês eu
não sei se eu ficar assustados eu fiquei
surpreendido porque isso aqui parece
mesmo um ovo de galinha pintados por
dentro então comecei o que vocês acham
que só o assunto foi alguém colocar aqui
os jogos acham que é algum animal poder
porque eu nunca vi uma caixa do governo
foi o dante porque eu tava comigo tem
vídeo eu acho que eu já desconfiava que
tem aqui qualquer coisa apesar de estar
a tirar muito podre que eu não consegui
ir pra casa botar muito fresco aqui
embaixo é porque o sol aquece muito em
cima mas contesta a prestação toda aqui
em baixo acaba por ficar frio então eu
não vou sair daqui tão cedo e vamos lá
falar pessoal eu não sei se gosto muito
tempo as minhas redes sociais mas agora
já consegue estar muito mais coisas pelo
menos não estranhemos 2 quiserem ficar
atentos a tudo que o posto se acumular
no instagram eu vou deixar aqui e se
integrar melhor foi mesmo sigam lá só
muito obrigado por tudo por um livro só
cumpriu o livro também já vai pra
terceira edição está a vender muito bem
você show mas muitas mesmo o melhor tipo
não é que o libertasse muito vendido o
melhor mesmo é o cb tem muitas pessoas
acompanharam o que eu faço assim um
livre e agora foi lançado já a terceira
edição é muita gente é muito apoio de
nós este vídeo ficou bem como eu queria
porque eu pensava que abrir outra coisa
mais bizarra dentro do ovo mas não é só
o governo por seguir o twitter será uma
criatura um curioso assim dentro do ovo
e fazia também ela de vídeo é otelo
vendo sem nada nenhum bicho é só não
quero que vocês façam também uma coisa
aí nos comentários e eu quero que vocês
comentem com essa tag eu quero e pois a
frente eu quero que vocês digam o que
querem ver aqui no canal que gosto mais
de ver experiências gosto mais de ver
vídeos com brinquedos gosto mais de ver
eu sei que vocês querem dividir os jogos
eu vou fazer ao menos por enquanto que o
de fazer o que vocês gostam mais e não
vou comentar o como irritar porque eu já
sei eu vou fazer mas não todas as
condições e sem ideais para fazer e
depois vou explicar por que o pt também
já não joga muito legal fred portanto eu
tenho obrigado a jogar para fazer como
entrar um jogador do ao magistério
pessoal que mantém mesmo quando o tempo
depende de vocês querem ver mesmo
contido que eu não tenha feito ainda
podem aumentar o iva a agulha faz o
motor logo vai fazer falta
claro que não vou fazer porque não tem
carta de condução nem tem moto mas bom
pessoal acho que vou voltar pra casa
porque já está a fazer calor até aqui
embaixo a todo suado mas o pessoal sério
como tem muito em baixo e que o que
vocês acham que vocês acham que o de
gravar e como eu não faço isso para mim
só para o umbigo tem que pensar sempre
vocês e que vocês gostam é muito
importante essa opinião não deixei mesmo
a vossa opinião sincera pessoal muito
obrigado e agora vamos voltar pra casa
eu estou a filmar ainda pessoal não
fechei o vídeo porque assim se eu cair
aumento fica filmado a ok você decida
que sozinho não vou conseguir filmar
porque é impossível mas só espero que
vocês tenham gostado aqui neste vídeo
eu nunca terminei um vídeo em cima dos
pilotos é a primeira vez que eu fiquei
mais pretende um estado e até a próxima